you you seem to have been very very
alone in your upbringing a lot of the uh
viet community down south in my time
biloxi mississippi some other places out
by you know dallas they they come in in
groups there's entire families that come
and they resettle you know from the
refugee camps where were you and your
mother and your brothers you know alone
in fayetteville
no so fayetteville i want to say is a is
a mixed town because of the military uh
population right so a lot of military
very mixed town but when you're saying
to vietnamese refugees i wanted to bring
this because this is another incident
that led me to who i am today was when i
was 11 first my uncle right he gave me
that speech another later on that year
my mother would drive across town and
then we would drive hours
hours she would drive to to drop off
food to these refugees
right
and i i told my mother so i asked my mom
like mom why do you do this why do we
waste all day driving across town to
give food to people that don't even care
they didn't even say thank you
my mother she stopped the car she
grabbed me and she she said look at me
she said you know son
it doesn't matter conditions or
circumstances if we can we must help
others and in doing so we create a
better world
you see it as confucialism so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]